[Music]
foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
Pippa Korea political editor at the
guardian and Harry Cole political editor
at the sun they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight we'll be
speaking to them in just a sec but let's
have a look first at what's on some of
those front pages
all out whoa that's how the Metro
describes what it calls the vicious
verbal blows being traded between Rishi
sunak and Boris Johnson over the former
prime minister's resignation honors list
time says that the commons privileges
committee has concluded that Mr Johnson
did mislead Parliament when he told MPS
he'd been advised that he did not break
covid-19 rules
in the midst of all this the mirror
speaks up for the families of people who
died from covid and says they deserve
better
and although Boris Johnson has now
resigned as an MP he tells the express
Express in an exclusive interview
believe me I shall return to Frontline
politics
the males says labor stands accused of
abandoning the law-abiding majority by
failing to back curbs on disruptive
eco-protest groups such as just stop oil
the guardian pippa's paper leads with
news of a woman who was jailed for
procuring drugs for an abortion after
the legal time limit had passed
the eye reports what it calls a Russian
intelligence agent is now living in the
UK with his family having been housed
under the government scheme to help
homeless Ukrainian families
the financial times so as a committee of
MPS is to question top officials at the
financial conduct authority over sexual
misconduct allegations made against
hedge fund manager Crispin OD
Harry's paper the sun focuses on the
aftermath of Manchester City's treble
winning celebrations showing Kyle Walker
helping a somewhat worse for wear Jack
grealish and the headline having treble
Jack
and the star has news of what it says
was a UFO crash in the 1930s that was
hushed up by the then Pope according to
a former U.S Air Force official
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by Pippa queer
and Harry Cole let's get started shall
we great to have you both with us thanks
so much for joining us
um kicking off with the front page of
the Daily Express that exclusive uh
interview that Boris Johnson has given
to the express where he says believe me
I shall return to Frontline politics
um I saw you give a little laugh at that
Harry what's your response tell us more
about this
I'm not sure if it's um with all due
respect to our friends at the express
I'm not sure if there's an interview and
more of a text message to be a very
short single quote from Boris Johnson
um something we've heard from him before
when he resigned of course as pm he said
hasta la vista baby I'll be back and um
obviously here is a thousand word
statement uh late on Friday night he
right at the end there uh ducked in
there a little a little reference to uh
I'm leaving Parliament for now
um look Boris Johnson I think almost
likes the idea of the comeback more than
it's ever going to happen it's a very
odd way of staging a sort of coup
against Rishi suneck as some people have
alleged he's doing uh by exiting the
stage so
um it's all sort of uh fighting talk I
think and today we've seen
astonishing barbs traded in public
between a prime minister and their
predecessor
um or an ex-priminister and their
successor Richard sunac has kept his
powder dry over the weekend he was away
in Washington until Friday we all flew
back from from DC and the sort of Boris
news blew up late on Friday night the
Prime Minister didn't respond to any of
the any of the barbs from Johnson over
the weekend but my gosh did he save up
his um his punch and um seen as a bit of
a technocrat quite a mild-mannered
polite man but you could tell he was
very angry and I can't remember a time
that a prime minister has gone so hard
after their predecessor only even the
days of of Gordon and Tony and and
Thatcher and Heath these these sort of
things take years to Bubble over what
we've got is the two big piece of the
conservative party trading public blows
12 months away from an election and you
just think what does the public make of
this it is an astonishing turn of events
yeah I can see you nodding there and
certainly it's extraordinary isn't it we
as Harry says we've seen these big
political feuds before but it's so rare
to see this public mudslinging and
inside the times they go into more
detail about uh some of you know what
Boris Johnson supposedly pressed Rishi
sunakon
yeah the time is has this well we know I
mean we knew that Boris Johnson wanted
to give his father Stanley Johnson a
Knighthood and there was a uh a story of
several weeks ago
um about it being about being blocked
obviously there's a distinction between
the peerages that Boris Johnson
um put on his list he wanted 16 of those
and then and and the uh the committee
that
um that goes through all these things
for the House of Lords blocked half of
them and then on the other hand this was
all the other honors so the the
knighthoods and the cbes and then bees
and so on which went through the cabinet
office for vetting and the time
suggestion is that um in the in the
recent discussion there was last week
you know last week when Russia Boris
Johnson sat down and tried to thrash out
some sort of compromise on this
um that um Boris Johnson had actually
pressed so like again for his father to
be awarded awarded a Knighthood exciting
the example of previous Prime Ministers
that have given family members
um gongs Theresa May
um obviously her husband Philip received
one and other other Ministry of prime
ministerial spices have in the past not
as far as I know Prime ministerial
parent although Stanley Johnson was of
course an MEP for some time and an
environmentalist but is nevertheless a
quite controversial figure
um not least in his attitude and some of
his behavior towards women
um so this is really just one example of
where the route between them erupted
and Boris Johnson is obviously feeling
very hard done by that
um Rishi sinak did not intervene on his
behalf And Delay the system the vetting
system so that the MPS that he wanted to
make peerages uh to meet peers uh could
could stay in in their seats for now but
still have a sort of a smooth transition
if you like to be to the House of Lords
ahead of the election but as Harry's
already said really bad blood between
the two men this evening and um and you
know that sort of conservative Blue on
Blue infighting the one thing part one
thing the public hates more than
anything is uh divided parties fighting
amongst themselves uh and because it
looks like they're they're just focused
on on you know their own Futures and
their own selves and not on all the many
issues facing the country like the cost
of living crisis the NHS
yeah and and Harry is certainly the
front page of the Metro uh calls it all
out War what do you make of this you
know public falling out that we that
we're now seeing play out do you think
that Boris Johnson is going to pose more
problems for Rishi sunak outside of
parliament or inside
well he's resigned formerly as an MP
today he is no longer an MP officially
um and he's you know he's upended
Downing streets weak uh quite
spectacularly once uh this week and I
wonder whether he'll do it do it again
look he's he's clearly aggrieved he
feels that he was misled perhaps not
directly perhaps he wasn't told a lie to
his face but misled by what Richard said
that didn't tell him though they clearly
Met 10 days ago in Parliament they had
secret peace talks as as as the Times
report and the Sunday Times reported
earlier on Sunday
um you know they discussed periods they
discussed Stanley Johnson's Knighthood
but two people left that meeting with
two very different interpretations of
what was promised Richie sunak is
adamant that he said I won't do a deal I
won't do a promise I won't I won't make
any any any any sort of bending of the
rules was what he came out publicly
today but Johnson was left with the
impression that his list was going to go
through without with those MPS names on
it now is there a conspiracy here or is
it up is it probably a bit of both
I just specs so what is clear is Downing
Street did not want three by-elections
this week
um announced it will come probably at
the end of July that is what they were
seeking to avoid however that's what
they've now got now Johnson is Raging he
feels like he's being betrayed Nadine
Doris is equally publicly vocalizing the
Betrayal narrative she's gone on talk TV
tonight straight for quote the Posh boys
who that she thinks has stitched her up
there's a girl from Liverpool who was
promised a peerage has had that taken
away because she was outspoken and had a
big mouth this is not gonna these people
don't have anything to lose really
they're not trying to hold their seats
they have a very high profile media sort
of platforms now and I can't see them
going quietly into the night so I think
that's why we saw Sue neck today come
out and try and punch Boris on the nose
quite hard to just give a little message
which is hang on mate look you know I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna take this lying
down and it seems that down in street
are going to fight fire with fire and
just very brief from you both before we
move on a you gov poll found only a
quarter of those asked want to see Boris
Johnson return he's obviously saying in
the express tomorrow I'll be back do you
see that happening Pippa
well we're we're reporting tonight in
the guardian that uh Rishi sinach would
block his return to the Tory candidates
list uh should he try and make a
comeback this side of a general election
so in short no I don't see that
happening anytime soon but as we've all
learned with Boris Johnson over very
many years is you never say never yeah
quite Harry briefly
there's no return for Boris Johnson and
he knows that and he's vocalized that to
people many times that until the
fundamentals change until the
Parliamentary makeup changes there is no
way back and if Richard wins the next
election by hooker by crook you know
it's his party for five years if he
loses because Boris Johnson really want
to come back and be lead of the
opposition but you know 10 years time
who knows yeah quite who knows uh let's
get on to the front page of your paper
Pippa the guardian
um really interesting and really
controversial story about a woman who's
been jailed uh for taking abortion pills
after the legal cut-off limit tell us
more about this
yes so um in England Wales and Scotland
uh most abortions legally have to take
place but before 24 weeks many of them
of course take place way before that in
the very early few early uh first few
weeks of pregnancy and after 24 weeks in
some limited circumstances for example
if a woman's life is in danger as a
result of a pregnancy or if there's no
Prospect of the baby surviving there are
certain medical situations where doctors
can make a judgment that actually it's
in uh boost their best interests
um uh to another pregnancy not to
proceed and but what's happened here is
that a mother of a mother of three
received what became known as pills by
post during the pandemic and from early
stage abortions pre-10 weeks
um it was uh introduced for unwanted
pregnancies after remote consultation
because obviously women it was harder
for women to get out to see their doctor
or to or to these clinics
um and she apparently
um when she applied for these drugs she
um had claimed that she was
um she was blue 10 weeks and actually by
the time she took them she was about
seven or eight months pregnant which is
way further Way Beyond
um the cutoff period and as a result uh
she's been she pleaded guilty
um but she has been sentenced and will
spend half of her sentence about just
over a year in custody and the other
half
um on license
um and that this is despite the fact
that uh
various this expert groups so
um the Royal College of Obstetricians
and various other pregnancy
um the Royal College of midwives raise
other experts groups had written a
letter signed a mitigation plea to the
judge in an attempt to uh to sort of
warn him or warn the judge that they
potentially were setting out a dangerous
precedent putting women off uh going for
support and help should they need it
later in pregnancy and that of course uh
this woman clearly was in a very fragile
emotional state in this prison the best
place for a mother of three that's
obviously been through very difficult
circumstances so you know this is a
story which will prompt or no doubt
strong views on either side of the
abortion debate I mean it must be said
reminded that the vast majority of
people in this country support abortion
I think people get queasier the later it
happens
um and cases like this will inevitably
spark debates about what the right
limits are and whether women should be
punished regardless of the reasoning
behind it for taking action later on in
pregnancy as this woman did okay Peppa
yep a very sad story on many levels
thank you both so much we're just going
to cut to a short break and give you a
little bit of a breather coming up we'll
have more from the papers including this
story on the front page of tomorrow's ft
their headline Berlusconi dies at 86
leaving Big questions for Maloney's
right-wing government we'll have more of
that coming up
[Music]
foreign
political editor at the guardian and
Harry Cole political editor at the sun
let's kick off with you if I may Harry
an article in your paper uh tomorrow
about Sadiq Khan's office uh Banning the
reference to men and women what's going
on
you might wonder whether Sadiq Khan
would spend most of his time tackling
the Deep problems at the Met or perhaps
storing knife crime in the capital or
congestion the fact you can't really get
around the tubes overheating today but
no uh the Sun have got a hold of his um
his style guide so to speak where staff
at City Hall have been told not to save
men and women because apparently that's
uh that's offensive I'm not quite sure
to who to uh not to say EU migrants to
say uh for let's say London is from
Europe and various other things on this
list that go through that reads like a
sort of almost like a private artist
spoof of someone desperately trying to
be ultra awoke and and hip and right on
but actually just sounding a little bit
mad and and maybe a bit confusing for
many people
um Pippa the financial times
um leading with a tribute to Berlusconi
of course who who's died at the age of
86 and questions about what that could
mean for Georgia Maloney's uh coalition
yeah I mean
uh seems to be around forever doesn't he
I remember those pictures of him and
Tony Blair meeting on the on various
trips to Tuscany a long and
controversial career
um that re-ranged as a ft says for
billionaire media magnet to trailblazing
populist
um and he was on and off leader of Italy
for over a decade
um in total uh which was marked of
course by the criminal investigation
it's his business Affairs and indeed the
sex scandals who can forget the bunga
bunga parties
um and uh but he was always active even
towards the end of his life in Italian
politics and he played a leading role in
the crisis as he brought down Mario
dragi's government last year and helped
to form Georgia Maloney's ruling
Coalition but because of that uh key
role that he played at that point uh
questions have been questions have been
asked about the division of power
between Maloney's right-wing Coalition
now and the future of his Sports Hetalia
party
um which doesn't have a clear successor
so
um you know it remained an instrumental
and influential figure in Italian and
European politics
um despite his advancing years uh and
despite the fact he was no longer in
power himself uh he was very much
somebody who was sitting there pulling
the strings so a major change in Italian
politics tonight uh with the death of
Silvio beresconi